قبل قليل اخفق مجلس النواب الامريكي للمره
السابعه في انتخابي رئيس جديد له فشله
مرشحوا الحزب الجمهوري زعيم الاغلبيه في
المجلس كذا المكرتي في الحصول على
الاغلبيه اللازمه من الاصوات وهي
218 صوتا للفوز بالمنصب في حين حصل
منافسها ديمقراطيه حكيم جفرجيس على 200
و12 صوتا ويهديه النتيجه سيطروا المجلس
الى اجراء تصويت تنتهي من لاختياري رئيسا
له
معنى الان من الكونجرس مراسله الجزيره
بيسان ابو كويك اهلا بك في بيسان على ما
يبدو هذه الخلافات
مستعصيه على الحل لدى الاغلبيه الجمهوريه
ما ينعكس على قرارها بشان انتخاب رئيس
المجلس النواب ماذا يحدث
الى اين تتجه الامور
ثامنه من التصويت قبل لحظات تم ترشيح كابن
مكارسي للمره الثامنه لجوله تصويت تامينات
كي يتراسا المجلس من قبل ان ابراهيم مع
طبعا حين اتينا صبيحه اليوم كان هناك
تسريبات حول مفاوضات جرت حتى فجر اليوم
وتنازلات جديده قدمها مقار في لي هذه
الزمره المعارضه والتي باتت حتى هنا تسمى
بالمتمرده من التنازلات تنازلات حتى
متعلقه بكيفيه تسيير عمل المجلس وحتى قرار
سحب الثقه من رئيس المجلس لكي يتمكن
المشرع واحد فقط من طرح مشروع يسحب فيه
الثقه من رئيس المجلس وامور اخرى لها
علاقه بالجنه نافذه وهي لجنه التوابط
والتي تحكم عمل التصويت على التشريعه داخل
مجلس النواب هذه تنازلات كنا قد بدانا
ايضا نص مع كمال مولان من الكتله همم
المؤيده لمقارثي والتي يبلغ عددها اكثر من
200 عضو باطن كالاصوات باتت تشعر ان هذه
الزمره الصغيره ستتحكم حتى لو فاز مكارتي
في نهايه هذه المعركه الطويله بعمل المجلس
وانها هي الان هو حكم الاقليه على
الاغلبيه ولكن حين دخلنا تصويت الجوله
السابعه لم يغير اي من المشرعين من هذه
المجموعه ال 20 مشرعا من اصواتهم ولم يحرز
اي تقدم مقر في بي حتى استماره اي من
اولئك ال 20 هذه المجموعه ايضا ايمان
مقسمه ربما لمجموعتين هناك حوالي خمس الى
ست مشرعين منها من بينهم نائب الجمهوري
مات جايتس وهو من المقربين جدا من ترامب
وحتى انه اليوم انتخبت ترامب في هذه
الجوله السابعه ليتراس مجلس النواب
وكان مقر في مع انه انتقدت رائعه عفوا
جايتس انتقد ترامب بالامس لانه دعا هذه
المجموعه لتاييد مقاسي
هذه المجموعه هؤلاء الخمسه سته جميعهم
مناهضون لمكارت جمله وتفصيلا وحتى النائبه
لورن بورد احدى احدى اعضاء هذه المجموعه
قالت بالامس انها سترفض اي شخص وتعارض اي
شخص حتى من المجموعه القياديه الحاليه في
مجلس النواب من الجمهوريين همم الشق الاخر
من هذه المجموعه المعارضه ما يسمى بالفريز
ان كوكيز او تجمع الحريه وهو اا مجموعه من
اليمنيين المتشددين الذين كانوا قد اثاروا
متاعب لرؤساء سابقين لمجلس النواب من
الجمهوريين قبل همم سنوات
هؤلاء هذه المجموعه هي المجموعه التي
تفاوض على تنازلات لكي تحصل على صلاحيات
وسلطات اكبر في عمل النواب وهو يتقدم ولكن
حتى اللحظه رغم هذه المفاوضات والتنازلات
لم همم لم ينقل اي من هؤلاء اصواتهم الى
مقايسه شكرا لك بلسان ابو كويك مراسله
الجزيره كنت معنا من الكونفرس